[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous bonjour et
bienvenue dans sénat stream votre
émission hebdomadaire avec public sénat
on a le plaisir de recevoir un sénateur
ou une sénatrice qui vient répondre à
vos questions cette semaine on a le
plaisir de recevoir
stéphane le rudulier bonjour bonjour
merci de m'avoir invité jamais arrivé
bien installé très bien super tant mieux
on va passer une heure ensemble stéphane
verrue du lit on va apprendre à vous
connaître vous êtes aujourd'hui sénateur
les républicains des bouches du rhône
j'ai beaucoup de questions pour vous
mais c'est surtout vos questions que je
vais poser les questions que vous m'avez
transmises dès hier pour le sénateur
notre invité cette semaine bonjour à
vous si vous nous regardez donc sur
twitch actuellement en direct bonjour
aussi si vous nous regardez sur public
sénat le canal 13 de la tnt
alors on va faire votre portrait
stéphane rudulier on va apprendre à vous
connaître
mais avant ça je voudrais qu'on aborde
des sujets d'actu c'est parti pour le
moment actu évidemment l'actualité cette
semaine comment ne pas en parler c'est
la question du coc vide la gestion du
coc vide par le gouvernement vous êtes
sénateur des bouches du rhône d'abord
une question très simple elle en est où
la situation épidémique dans votre
département ou tel et elle est toujours
inquiétante est d'ailleurs très
préoccupante au but de ce qui s'est
passé samedi je pense qu'on aura
localisé des questions d'ailleurs ville
de marseille où il ya quand même des
personnes qui sont totalement totalement
irresponsable et ce qu'il fait penser
que malheureusement n'est pas encore
sorti d'affaires au niveau des bouches
du rhône mais au niveau de la de la
france entière la clé temps et je ne
cesse de répéter de vacciner vacciner
vacciner en masse pour pouvoir sortir
définitivement de cette crise vacciner
vacciner mais confiné aussi un peu alors
la notion de confinement territorialisée
c'est ce que nous réclamions depuis
novembre dernier
voilà vous savez eu du coup 16 des
landes allemand seize départements ceci
dit dans le confinement ou dans
déconfinement en confinement ce que je
déplore c'est la lisibilité des mesures
gouvernementales
c'est à dire et à dire vrai c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné vous devez avoir
confiance aux annonces gouvernementales
et la succession de couacs depuis un an
fait qu'à une certaine forme de défiance
qui est préjudiciable à la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
je voudrais citer un exemple lundi cette
fameuse attestation retirer en 24 heures
et c'est un qcm c'était plus une
attestation en feuilles avec 10 cases à
cocher
on nous avait dit on va responsabiliser
les français il ya de cela un mois nous
avons compris le message
nous allons territorialisée les mesures
nous allons prendre le pouls des élus
locaux et j'ai pas eu l'impression ou si
ce n'est à nice puisque dans les
alpes-maritimes soleil en effet
département qualité concertés ces
mesures qui a été concerté je ne suis
pas sûr que la concertation ait eu lieu
sur l'ensemble des départements
une question de zut zut qui nous demande
pour vous est ce qu'il faudrait
s'adapter plus rapidement en fonction
des régions
pas seulement une question de
régionalisation mais la question la
rapidité absolument on n'est pas assez
réactifs je pense que par rapport aux
taux d'incidence par exemple
effectivement il faudrait être que les
préfet prenne la main à vous pensez à
wil décision préfectorale
écoutez vous avez bien de tous pourquoi
compliquer c'est le préfet il obéit à
son ministre weil lobby nous verrons
donc l'acquisition et le ministère qui
gère la crise
j'ai pas si vous avez remarqué en selle
conseil de défense c'est le conseil de
défense et à travers le ministère de la
santé et les ars mais si on est en
guerre comme ça a été le propos d'
emmanuel macron je pense que le
ministère de l'intérieur et plus à même
à travers l'état déconcentré de gérer la
crise territorialement
ça veut pas dire pour autant que le
ministère de la santé ne peut pas
participer
forcément aux décisions mais on voit
très bien que la grèce est en souffrance
dans l'ensemble des régions de france
malheureusement
achraf vous demande une question simple
est ce que vous pensez qu'on va pouvoir
venir à la plage chez vous cet été
difficile à dire je
fondamentalement je pense que si on
vaccine en masse on pourra le faire
est ce que les objectifs seront tenus
est ce que nous aurons assez
suffisamment ces deux vaccins puisque la
problématique de la vaccination
c'est au delà de la première à tiques de
la logistique c'est la problématique de
l'approvisionnement en interne à
s'amender assez de vaccins
est-ce qu'il fallait passer
exclusivement à travers l'union
européenne pour commander des vaccins
la question mérite d'être posée le
gouvernement argue que c'est la
production qui pose un problème c'est
pas le gouvernement qui est en faute ses
astra zeneca et enfin voila c'est les
laboratoires qui ne peuvent pas produire
plus le voilà et c est ce que vous
pensez que le gouvernement a raison
où est ce qu'ils se cachent des relais
la beau jeu en fait clairement il aurait
fallu dès le départ sur ses vaccins
puisque étant donné que c'était une une
sitution une situation quand même de
crise mondiale faire que en sorte que
les chaînes de production soit des
concentrés au niveau des pays pour avoir
suffisamment de volume pour répondre aux
demandes de chaque pays
une question de tom est ce que vous
allez vous faire vacciner
monsieur pleure bien sûr vous n'êtes pas
en défiance vis-à-vis du vaccin non non
il ya eu ce débat avec le fameux
astrazeneca voire même bien avant
puisque les français étaient au départ
majoritairement réticents avec six
nations et au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée ils se sont aperçu que j'étais
le seul moyen pour l'heure puisque on
n'a pas encore de traitement contre le
lakovic 19 c'est le seul moyen pour
lutter efficacement donc oui je me ferai
je me ferai vacciner
peu importe le vaccin compromis
n'occupera alors oui c'est aussi une
question que j'allais vous poser est ce
que vous allez vouloir choisir votre
vaccin parce que certains parlementaires
de 10 mois je voudrais choisir le vaccin
le labo jeunes ont pourtant en ce qui me
concerne je prendrai ce conte ce qu on
injectera jugé pas choisir mon type de
vaccin je reviens sur la gestion par le
gouvernement de cette de cette crise du
coc vide est ce que selon vous emmanuel
macron a fait un pari en janvier on ne
confie non pas comme le lui recommandait
le conseil l'alluré zone de
scientifiques il a eu raison de le faire
figurer je vais pas décrier c'est ce que
j'ai dit le politique avait repris le
pouvoir sur le comité scientifique qui
était dans une dans une logique
d'enfermement des dents principe de
précaution à eau
trans il a eu raison de prendre ce pari
puisque de toute façon économiquement ça
avait un impact catastrophique pour la
française que la france
or est-ce véritablement subi un recond
finement globale de 15 jours de trois
semaines d'un mois économiquement
mentalement socialement je pense qu'on
n'en avait pas les épidémiologistes ont
écouté les dès les premières semaines du
mois de février lui ont donné raison à
trois semaines
oui mais le mois de mars le mois de mars
est un peu plus compliqué nous verrons
et je pense que avec ces mesures qui
arrivent nous verrons dans quinze jours
s'il y a eu des effets positifs mais de
toute façon ces mesures là ne sont que
des palliatifs et j'en reviens toujours
à la même chose par rapport à la
vaccination ce que je des portes plus de
la part du gouvernement ce n'est pas les
mesures qui est obligé de prendre en
réaction du piquet des mots logique
c'est le fait qu'il n'ait pas
suffisamment pensés sa stratégie
vaccinale
comment est-ce que vous expliquer la
difficulté
visible du gouvernement à prendre des
mesures anticipatoire pour le coc u19
c'est une question qui vous est posée
par hermès tout et c'est quand même
difficile on a là je vais défendre un
peu le gouvernement parce que imaginons
qu'un jour on arrive en responsabilité
on est à gérer une crise sanitaire du
passé l'unité connaître ça veut dire
qu'on connaît parfaitement le virus et
comment réagit le virus en fonction de
quelle considération des saisons des
sépales cas pour l'on découvre levure
hisse au fur et à mesure il est vrai
qu'en un an
on a quand même produit un vaccin c'est
un exploit
alors je parle de à l'échelle du monde
un pape au niveau de la france
et effectivement il est plus en réaction
tout à l'heure on parlait du de la
réactivité
parfois on territorialement c'est pas
assez réactifs puisqu'on attend
peut-être un peu trop longtemps mais je
ne peux pas dire que le gouvernement en
l'état
ne réagit pas par rapport à des
situations qui sont parfois
difficilement maîtrisable on pensait et
même le comité scientifique pensé qu' il
y aurait eu un pic et mods et
épidémiologique au mi février
il n'a pas eu lieu il a été tellement
sûr sur mi mars
et rien explique le fait qu'on est
décalée d'un mois ce pitt le pic est
dense et intéressant donc je rappelle
que vous êtes un sénateur d'opposition
vont siéger au sens républicain mais
vous n'êtes pas non plus dans une dans
une dans une accusation du gouvernement
qui fait ou mal de a à z
non ce que je déplore c'est la stratégie
de communication jeu parce que j'estime
que le fait de faire d'instrumentaliser
un peu ses conférences de presse
tous les jeudis à 18 heures en disant
mais qu'est ce qui va nous tomber dessus
ça c'est ça fait plus peur je pense aux
français qu autre chose
et puis derrière c'est la stratégie
vaccinale qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
enjeux
j'ai vu une question passé dans le chatt
quelqu'un qui vous demandent 'est-ce que
vous anticipez la création d'un
vaccinodromes au stade vélodrome de
marseille
je pense que c'est déjà le kayak
cynodrome ça y est c'est déjà le cas à
mon avis ou bien désolé là c'est le
parisien qui part du coach alors du coup
ça se passe comment ça se passe de la
solution d vaccinodromes c'est même il
faut faire ça il faut le faire on peut
pas dire on vaccine en masse et on se
prive de deux vaccinodromes qui permet
de gérer le flux le flux des patients
que répondez-vous à olivier ferrand qui
pointe du doigt parfois l'hypocrisie de
certains élus notamment les républicains
qui réclamaient l'ouverture des
restaurants à marseille au mois de
septembre octobre novembre au moment où
commencer la deuxième vague et qui
aujourd'hui reproche parfois
gouvernement d'être trop dur danser
danser dans ses mesures non moi je pense
qu'on est tout à fait logique
on parle de la réouverture des
restaurants j'ai prôné il faut il faut
être très très réactif et est également
avoir des réponses territorialisées vous
avez des départements où les taux
d'incidence sont très faibles notamment
dans l'ouest de la france pourquoi ne
pas réouvrir les restaurants les bars à
l'échelle d'un département pour voir
comment également se comporte le virus
dès lors qu'on réouvre avec un protocole
sanitaire très strict
je sais que renaud muselier martine
vassal le président de région et la
présidente du département avaient
ainsi s'ils ont reçu il faut ré ouvrir
les restaurants à un moment donné le
quoi qu'il en coûte doit s'arrêter parce
que économiquement c'est les générations
futures qui vont payer la facture du coc
vide on va continuer à parler de ces
sujets là et des sujets institutionnels
mais avant ça je voudrais qu'on fasse
votre père très et qu'on apprendre qu'on
apprenne à vous connaître
c'est parti pour le moment portrait
[Musique]
alors qui êtes vous stéphane rudulier
une première question assez simple vous
avez fait quoi comme bac 1 bac
économique et social bac b à l'époque
ac.b à l'époque d'accord vouliez faire
quoi plus tard masi pas sénateur
non non je je je ne savais pas
exactement ce que je voulais faire à
l'âge de 18 ans et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui ne savent pas à
quoi ils sont destinés donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle ma carrière
professionnelle je n'aime pas fait que
de la politique
j'ai une parenthèse dans le privé alors
à confirmer leur racontez moi du coup
vous avez votre bac économique et social
haut-la-main où vous l'avez ric rac
non je le ric rac ou le mans je ne sais
pas qu'est ce que vous faites après
alors alors après je m'oriente vers des
la faculté vers une maîtrise de sciences
de l'information et de communication
ok et derrière je m'intègre dans le dans
le tissu industriel avec je suis
d'origine du nord de la france de
maubeuge précisément je ne suis pas un
buteur d'accord n'est pas des injures
aux annonces des fêtes du koro d'aliens
d'accord le natif et d'ailleurs je
prends une carrière dans l'industrie
notamment la fabrique de faire demande
mais aussi chez peugeot peugeot citroën
également avant de reprendre les études
de d'intégrer la chose publique puisque
j'avais déjà fait quelques stages en
collectivités territoriales
effectivement c'est quelque chose à leur
critique qu'est ce qui s'est passé à
quel moment on passe de l'industrie à la
politique parce qu'on parle beaucoup des
politiques ils vont dans le pas j'ai
toujours une passion pour la politique
alors à quel moment dans votre vie
stéphane rigoler la politique arrive
comment ça s'est passé l'âge de 10 ans
je regardais l'heure de vérité c'était
tous les dimanches à 11h avec alain
duhamel albert du roy je pense jamais à
10 ans tu sais moi je regarde ces
décharges et fromagers
je ne dis pas que c'était vous qui
allumait la télévision il y avait la
politique est là en famille non il n'y a
pas de politique
mes parents ne regardez pas j'étais seul
devant lé sénat remet alors elle vient
d'où cette fascination passionné par les
par les hommes politiques quel que soit
le parti c'est marrant fin ouais ouais
j'avais je pense que il me fascinait et
surtout ce format d'émission pendant une
heure le la personne arrivée avec ses
solutions sont peut-être pas les bonnes
solutions je n'en sais rien mais et ça
ça me fascine et vous avez des souvenirs
de l'heure de vérité de l'est alors
l'heure de vérité pour ceux qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui c'était une
émission a rendez vous télé hebdomadaire
extrêmement important avec l'invité de
la semaine le politique qui venait
littéralement face aux français répondre
aux questions d'olivier duhamel et jeu
là j'ai le souvenir de charles pasqua
ça devait donc ça j'ai souvenir de
charles pasqua et de sa prestation
pourtant je n'ai jamais connu à quelle
époque du coup à ce moment là ce que
charles pasqua il a été ministre de
l'intérieur à ce moment là je crois en
fonte pour qu'on était au s1 15 ou la
zone ont peut-être années 80-90 l'été il
n'était pas ministre l'intérieur met
enfin en tout cas c'était déjà une
personnalité une personnalité de droite
et c'est vrai que sa prestation mais
m'est resté est ce que j'adorais c'est
la fin où il venait signer avec une
phrase pour synthétiser en fait leur
pensée du jour ça y est peut-être des
jeunes qui nous regardent et qui aiment
voir renault stéphane le rudulier
aujourd'hui et qui sur quelques quelques
décennies ce pan sénateurs j'espère que
ça va susciter débats
c'est à vous de voir ça c'est voilà
c'est d'essayer de faire une bonne
prestation afin de ckoi ça dépend plus
de boucles de moi mais alors du coup à
quel moment vous engager parce que donc
la fascination quand on regarde à la
télévision des hommes et des femmes
politiques la comprend à quel moment
vous vous engagez comment ça s'est fait
dans votre bilan
c'est en fait je m'engage parce que
j'intègre une collectivité territoriale
une commune gilles de 13 mille habitants
dans les bouches du rhône en tant que
directeur de cabinet d'accord donc
certains collaborateurs s'estompe
collaborateurs mais je crois beaucoup
j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler à la formation tout au long de
la vie je pense que effectivement par
rapport à nos parents qui ont embrassé
une carrière dans une entreprise qui
faisait 30 ans 40 ans dans la même
entreprise
on n'est plus dans la même logique quand
on regarde le monde du travail l'heure
actuelle mais qu'il faut faciliter
également la formation à un moment donné
de sa vie
mettre entre parenthèses sa carrière
professionnelle pour reprendre les
études ou en alternance également où
l'employeur facilite la chose et ce qui
m'a permis d'aller jusqu'au doctorat en
sciences politiques et donc alors nous
voilà donc c'est donc on fait un type
est un saut dans le temps vous bifurquer
après l'industrie pour aller vers la
chose publique
vous faites des études de droit c'est ça
oui alors deux
deux intègrent l'école de journalisme de
marseille puis après sciences po
jusqu'au doctorat et récemment en 2016
je me passionne pour le droit et je
retombe à la faculté de droit où je
j'entreprends ma deuxième thèse en droit
public ça vous avez déjà une première
thèse que vous avez soutenu en 2011 et
là vous êtes en train d'engager une
deuxième depuis trois quatre ans depuis
3 4 ans et et et tout en étant sénateur
oui parce que je mangeais tu les as
comment vous faites cesser
je sais un peu mais deux personnalités
j'adore apprendre
j'adore aussi essayé de transmettre
quelque peu même et mes connaissances
donc j'enseigne également et ce qui me
permet aussi de prendre du recul par
rapport à la politique politicienne
également et ça c'est très important
thaler en parlant du projet de réforme
constitution va parler oui effectivement
le fait d'être aussi dans la matière
permet d'appréhender peut-être avec un
peu plus de hauteur la chose donc
aujourd'hui vous êtes enseignant
chercheur à l'université une la question
est venue très rapidement en internautes
en l'occurence guy guillotin vous
demande est ce que vous avez à faire
face à l'islam au gauchisme à
l'université ce qui nous concerne à la
fac de droit d'aix en provence non je
n'ai rien dit on ce qui me concerne à la
fac de droit d'aix en provence alors
quoi alors c'est un mythe
le non non non c'est pas un mythe
quand on boit
des événements comme un lieu paix de
grenoble on peut pas dire que c'est un
mythe
c'est alors de quoi est-il le nom selon
d'un nom de quoi c'est le nom cet islam
au gauchisme dont parlait plutôt de
séparatisme et fragmentation de la
société et ce que je j'ai du mal à
comprendre
un étudiant est fragile par définition
quand on a 18 ans 19 ans on en train de
former son jugement par rapport à la
société nous vous le savez nos valeurs
c'est l'universalisme la ministre tout à
l'heure la rappeler ça veut dire que
notre vivre ensemble ne laisse pas place
au communautarisme mois la séparation
par rapport à notre race par rapport à
notre culture par rapport à notre façon
de penser et c'est vrai que quand on
voit un syndicat comme l'unef prône et
des réunions ou non mixtes interdit aux
blancs c'est quand même très choquant
l'unef justifie sa en expliquant que ce
sont des groupes de paroles qui
permettent à des victimes de
discrimination de pouvoir s'exprimer en
toute liberté
vous pensez clairement qui a pas de
discrimination parfois vis-à-vis de
femmes blanches c'est pourquoi pas moi
je ne dis rien je trouve juste que le
dialogue il m'a l'air totalement
impossible et que là il ya un truc est
fermée entre ce qu'explique l'unef est
ce que lui reproche se demander sa
dissolution
je conseille à landrais mieux justement
à l'heure actuelle de défendre les
étudiants qui sont dans une situation
psychologique quand même désastreuse
c'est les cours à distance fait je feins
janssen donc je peux vous le dire des
cours à distance pendant 1h30 2h
ça demande une attention que ça soit
pour le prof mais également pour
l'étudiant qui doit être décuplée on
n'est pas en présentiel et là on
n'entend pas lui neuf là dessus alors
c'est mais je comprenais je suis pas du
tout en inventant de l'unef et non mais
j'ai l'impression qu'au contraire l'unef
ne parle que la situation sociale des
étudiants est qu'on lui rappelle qu'on
lui parle que d'islam au gauchisme alors
que le sujet n'est pas là pour faire des
réunions
c'était un sujet pour l'unef c'est pour
les opposants à l'unef que ça en est un
c'est quand même l'unef qui les
organisent
ça oui mais c'est joris qui leur pose
des questions sur ce sujet alors que
l'unef ne parle que de la situation
socioéconomique des étudiants je suis
pas ce genre je sais pas par rapport à
l'iut de grenoble le fait de relayer une
de mettre au pilori
deux professeurs ça soit 2 le rôle de
l'unef le rôle de l'unef c'est de
défendre les étudiants c'est pour ça
qu'on a réclamé la dissolution et là je
suis très ferme
l'unef n'a plus sa place en tant que tel
il faut rentrer une association qui
défendent et qui met l'étudiant au
centre de ses préoccupations à vous
demander ce que vous mettez un signe
égal entre générations identitaire et
l'unef
vous savez même en dhr c'est c'est du
communautarisme
bien sûr génération identitaire il ya eu
un principe de fermeté de la part du
ministre de l'intérieur que vous
soutenez qu'il faut peser puisque c'est
le conseil d'état qui tranchera
j'avais quinze jours sur le décret du
conseil des ministres pour leur
génération identitaire n'a pas été
condamné par la justice pour ses jazy
agissements par contre son affichage on
le connaît mais les causes produisent
les mêmes effets il n'y a pas de place
pour le séparatisme en france et quand
on est en train dans une semaine de
d'étudier de d'examiner le texte sur le
renforcement des valeurs et des
principes de la république
quand on voit des associations
étudiantes ou des groupuscules essayer
de fragmenter la société il faut qu'on
ait une réponse que le politique et la
justice c'est une réponse
alors vous avez commencé à aborder un
petit peu ce sujet là puisqu'on était
encore en train de faire votre portrait
c'est de vous comprendre
vous êtes un homme de droite aujourd'hui
il vient d'où cet engagement à droite
c'est quoi ces valeurs il ya eu un
moment dans votre quart parcours
personnel vous avez rejoint un combat un
événement d'actualité une personnalité
politique peut-être non c'est par
rapport à mes valeurs je vous ai parlé
je crois je crois beaucoup au travail je
compte beaucoup la formation tout au
long de tout au long de la vie je crois
beaucoup à la méritocratie
car j'aime l'ordre germe la sécurité
j'estime que sans sécurité on peut pas
développer de politiques publiques on
peut pas parler de culture peut pas
parler d'économie on peut donc c'est
vrai que ce sont ces valeurs ce socle et
puis après le peut-être la rencontre
avec alors quand j la rencontre aller
virtuel avec des personnages comme comme
chirac comme comme sarkozy qu'on qui
m'ont amené à à m'engager beaucoup plus
en profondeur au sein au sein de mon
parti oui alors j'ai eu plusieurs
questions de des internautes au sujet
justement du parti les républicains vous
vous en doutez évidemment une question
très simple bernès qui vous demande quel
est l'espace politique pour les
républicains
entre la république en marché leur
assemblée nationale c'est vraiment de la
place pour vous bien sûr ah ouais mais
sur quel est le corpus idéologique de la
république en marche
y'en a pas corpus j'allais vous demandez
de quoi le maquereau nice mais qu'il le
non pardon de quoi le maquereau nice
mais est il le nom pour vous mais
attendez le maquereau nice ne repose que
sur un seul homme emmanuel macron un
homme qui mène une politique de droite
qui devrait vous plaire normalement non
pardon il peut pas mener eu uniquement
une politique de droite c'est le grand
écart entre des valeurs de gauche et des
valeurs de droite
regardez les ministres c'est intéressant
ça bien sûr et le maquereau nisme
s'arrêtera et la république en marche
s'arrêtera quand s'arrêtera emmanuel
macron ou en 2022 ou en 2027
si vous voulez dans l'histoire de la
delà de notre république
le clivage gauche droite a toujours
existé il existe encore il est pas
dépasser pour vous assure que non qu'il
existe encore et c'est très riche parce
que comme vous êtes au sénat où il n'y a
pas de république relève plus de 23
quand vous vous êtes en commission et
vous débattez d'un point de vue
idéologique avec la gauche c'est ça la
richesse du débat démocratique
parce que là on a un affrontement
idéologique on a des arguments
rationnels
on a une véritable délibérations entre
nous
ce qui n'explique ce qui n'existe pas
avec la république en marché
ce qu'est ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que je suis un peu nostalgique de
ça et nous avons une responsabilité
énorme la gauche comme la droite sur le
fait que les français ne croit plus en
ce clivage parce qu'on a échoué tour à
tour depuis 30 ans par rapport à nos
politiques qu'on doit mettre en oeuvre
et donc je pense sincèrement que
intéressant c'est ses projets politiques
là pour répondre à votre question
première
il faut que les républicains il faut que
le parti socialiste ou alors peu importe
où les ceux qui vont porter les valeurs
de gauche et ceux qui vont porter les
valeurs de droite dans les années à
venir
peu importe nous du parti on puisse
vraiment refonder leur logiciel
intellectuelle leur projet politique
pour avoir une offre crédible vis-à-vis
de la population et c'est par l'offre
que les citoyens retourneront et
participeront à l'élection
en démocratie le juge de paix c'est
l'électeur absolument les lecteurs
aujourd'hui n'y croit plus vraiment la
seule une image de droite dont vous
parlez oui et c'est d'où ma question de
votre espace politique entre la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national encore une fois la droite dont
vous parlez j'ai du mal à voir émerger
j'ai du mal à voir mais parce que il
faut qu'on travaille sur notre logiciel
il faut qu'on travaille sur des réponses
fortes par rapport aux problématiques
actuelles et qu'on puisse essayer de
convaincre les électeurs du bien fondé
de la guerre
le front national fin de leur assemblée
en juillet je suis assez cruel c'est un
amateurisme incroyable et c'est pas
parce qu'on est d'accord parfois sur le
constat que nos solutions sont les mêmes
on parle notamment l'immigration sur les
sujets d'immigration de sécurité
on peut penser ce sont la même chose que
leur assemblée nationale et la droite
c'est la même chose mais c'est pas vrai
du tout les sur les sujets économiques
c'est pareil il faut que véritablement
on arrive à faire passer nos idées des
idées novatrices pour arriver à d'ici 10
15 ans voire 20 ans à avoir ce ce
challenge qu'on a à refaire de la france
une puissance mondiale qui est en train
de mal heureusement pour l'heure de
cette cholet une question de
achraf qui vous demande simplement est
ce que la politique menée actuellement
par le gouvernement est une politique de
droite je devrais pas le dire
vous seriez pas dire non je sois pas dû
les personnalités comme jean castex
gérald darmanin bruno le maire sont
issus de vos rangs sont issus de la
droite
le gouvernement est plus à droite qu'à
gauche non je suis pas le gouvernement
je sais pas une somme d'individus où on
pèse alors je vais dire au sort alors
c'est une politique volontairement
européenne libérale sur le plan
économique
autoritaire sur le point de vue de la
sécurité autoritaire un point de vue de
la sécurité dans la pression des
manifestations sur la police non non je
suis la fiancée j'ai du mal à admettre
les marqueurs du maquereau nisme en fait
parce que c'est un peu tout et le
contraire de tout il ya un double
discours chez emmanuel macron selon vous
plus sûres il sera la même chose en
fichez s'est il fait le grand écart
il est constamment en train de faire le
grand écart est de donner des messages à
différents électorats et c'est pour ça
que c'est très peu lisible
c'est très peu lisible intéressant une
question de bol à qui vous demandez ce
que vous avez un avis sur le mode de
désignation du candidat des républicains
pour 2022 la primaire vous êtes vacciné
mauvais souvenir la primaire vous est
peut-être parce que la primaire pour
pour moi c'est pas le l'essence des
partis de droite
c'est vrai faut être très clair vous
regardez l'histoire de la droite et bien
c'est logiquement le chef de parti qui
était au premier tour de la
présidentielle parce qu'il a d'abord
rassembler sa famille politique sur un
projet avant d'essayer de rassembler les
français
donc c'est vrai que je suis assez
vacciner maintenant le problème que l'on
a à l'heure actuelle c'est que le chef
de parti n'est pas candidat aux
élections présidentielles et ç'a
toujours été
il a toujours déclaré et que
malheureusement il va falloir quand même
qu'on trouve un système de départage
mais je ne pense pas que les primaires
soient là la bonne solution parce que ça
a causé de dégâts incroyables dans notre
famille politique le des guerres d'ego
incroyable qui a mené malheureusement à
des guerres de clans derrière et on est
seulement en train de se relever de
cette phase des primaires
mr opéra vous demande avec
l'accumulation des procédures
judiciaires à l'encontre de nicolas
sarkozy n'est-il pas temps pour les
républicains de se dé sarkozy fier elle
est intéressante cette question elle est
intéressante mais vous savez nicolas
sarkozy ne se réduit ce ne réduit pas
aux affaires c'est vrai il a une
influence régionale je vais vous offre
tout à l'heure de l'offre politique et
c'est une réponse aussi sur la
l'abstention ou la non participation des
électeurs est ce que vous savez que la
campagne présidentielle de 2007 à
rassembler le plus large panel des
lecteurs en france c'est à dire que ça
soit ségolène royal au 2e tour au 1er
nicolas sarkozy dans premier second tour
nicolas sarkozy et la percée le présent
le mieux élu quand l'un d'eux nombre de
vous en de voir air mais quand on
regarde et on peut être nostalgique de
cette période là le l'offre politique il
y avait que ce soit aussi bien ses
urines en rien nicolas sarkozy
effectivement ça laisse rêveur d'une
d'un projet qui a été conçu pendant 18
mois avant et qui a été aboutis à
travers une personnalité qui était
nicolas sarkozy
ce qu'il faut ce des sarkozy fier non il
faut surtout un nouveau projet pour pour
les français au niveau de notre notre
famille politique
nicolas sarkozy 2
l'impression parfois de soutenir
indirectement emmanuel macron je suis
pas sûr vous avez pas peur dans la sauce
sarkozy emmanuel macron avant le premier
tour pardon ça ou ça vous inquiète
l'idée qui est manuel que nicolas
sarkozy soutient emmanuel macron à mon
avis nicolas sarkozy ne soutiendra pas
emmanuel macron premier tour mais c'est
parce que il raisonne en président de la
république en ancien président de la
république il a une responsabilité aussi
d'être modéré par rapport à la fonction
même du président de la république et il
ne raisonne plus en tant que famille
politique c'est la raison pour laquelle
des fois ça peut perturber
effectivement est ce qu'il ya des
alliances là les républicains et la
république en marche pour les élections
régionales
à ma connaissance il n'y aura pas
d'alliance à notre connaissance de votre
région dans ma région non ce qui va
d'aller en salle aura pas d'alliance au
premier tour avec la république en
marche très bien
une question de docteur brown qui vous
demande tout simplement pourquoi
êtes-vous devenu sénateur commence assez
récente et à écouter
j'étais pas du tout destiné à devenir
sénateur en septembre 2020 c'est non
mais c'est toute la question c'est pour
ça je suis très content je vous ai
interviewé une interview des sénateurs
et sénatrices comment ça se fait dans
une ville qu'on devient ses adveraires
je vous ai expliqué moi je suis devenu
maire en 2000 2016 j'étais premier
adjoint avant 2014 2016 et en 2016 mon
prédécesseur me dit bon bah écoute c'est
maintenant j'arrête pour des raisons
personnelles familiales
vas-y prend la suite et il est vrai que
on a mené une politique pendant quatre
ans qui était je pense assez soutenu et
qu'en 2020 quand je me suis représenté
j'étais parti pour six ans avec un
véritable projet et c'est un concours
j'allais dire de circonstances où
effectivement j'ai toujours eu de
l'appétence pour le travail législatif
et ma famille politique martine vassal
renaud muselier sont venus me chercher
au mois de juillet en disant ben écoute
tu es assez jeune dans l'air compétents
écoute
est ce que ça te dit de d'aller au sénat
oui ils ont une démarche la démarche qui
est absolument la démarche qui a été
fait est une très belle démarche parce
qu'en fait vous savez que le sénat
l'article 24 de la constitution le dit
c'est véritablement véritablement le
représentant des collectivités
territoriales est derrière derrière cela
martine vassal et renaud muselier ont
voulu que chaque région chaque pays
chaque secteur de du département soient
représentés dans la composition de la
liste des sénatoriales ce qui nous a
permis puisque avant c'était concentrer
sur marseille ou aix et bien là on a
élargi à l'échelle du département
et chaque territoire du département a
été représentée par un sénateur ou en
tout cas un colistier vous convient de
changer les piles de mon micro en direct
chez sage et très bien passé vous avez
vu je les avais meublé merveilleusement
bien c'est les aléas du direct c'est
génial j'espère vous m'entendez bien du
coup je continue la discussion les
élections sénatoriales ont lieu
vous arrivez en septembre dernier au
sénat dans un contexte sanitaire un
petit peu particulier
comment c'est quand on est nouveau
sénateur a déjà c'est une émotion
particulière imagine le premier jour où
vous rentrez dans l'hémicycle j'avais eu
la chance de visiter le sénat puisque
jean claude gaudin m'avait m'avait
invité il ya quelques quelques années de
cela mais c'est une émotion singulière
et puis vous prenez le point de
de la charge qui ose dire parce que vous
arrivez quand même dans l'inconnu même
si vous lui enseignez vous savez le
travail législatif comment il se peut il
procède
mais quand vous êtes acteur de la
fabrique de la loin c'est différent
d'être un commentateur de tels textes de
telles décisions du conseil
constitutionnel ou du conseil d'état
c'est pas du tout le même le même sujet
et il est vrai que il faut prendre ça
avec beaucoup d'humilité et que la
période d'intégration d'adaptation elle
se fait progressivement
vous devez apprendre à connaître les
codes les principes les rouages de cette
belle et noble
si tu chéris absolument et donc voila
vous voilà devenu sénateur à partir de
septembre dernier puis on va parler du
sénat c'est parti pour le moment sénat
alors du coup comment est-ce que vous
l'envisagez votre rôle de sénateur quand
on devient sénateur en 2021 on met les
pieds dans une institution particulière
qui a une histoire qu'un rôle
institutionnel qui a aussi une
réputation l'a très bien aimé de
beaucoup de français
comment vous l'envisagez vous alors je
vais répondants de temps quand il dit
pas très bien mais je pense que les
français devraient se replonger dans
l'histoire politique de france
je vous rappelle que le bicamérisme moi
je suis un fervent défenseur du
bicamérisme pourquoi je vais demander
aux professeurs que vous êtes de
préciser de quoi on parle du camés risme
c'est les deux chambres
il faut vous avez raison nous sommes si
nous sommes dans un régime parlementaire
rationalisé
mais pourquoi le bicamérisme dans
l'histoire de france vous avez deux
périodes de très courte durée où il ya
eu qu'une seule chambre 1792 1795 cette
période là vous la connaissez aussi bien
que moi c'était la terreur à un très bon
souvenir c'est pas un très bon souvenir
où c'était le parlementaire actions
décidées
de la vie ou de la mort de telle ou
telle puisqu'il est il a été contre les
idées révolutionnaires et puis vous avez
eu 18 148 1851 2 décembre 1851 le coup
d'état de louis napoléon bonaparte et on
réinstaurant même où napoléon bonaparte
réinstaure la deuxième chambre
donc vous voyez je mets la parenthèse
bien évidemment entre 41 et 45
volontaires heureuse on la lit et vous
voyez le sénat toujours à un rôle de
sagesse et c'est d'autant plus vrai avec
le quinquennat le quinquennat a eu un
effet au niveau de l'assemblée nationale
où c'est en fait le l'exécutif qui a été
renforcée par rapport au législatif
c'est à dire que c'est une transposition
in extenso des projets de loin du
gouvernement et heureusement caisse
contre-pouvoir qui s'appelle le sénat
pour justement essayer d'amender les
projets de loin ou les propositions de
loi et mettre un peu de sagesse avec un
recul
nous on n'est pas sous perfusion de
l'élection présidentielle puisque là le
rythme de la vie politique
malheureusement édictées par l'élection
majeure la clé de voûte de nos
institutions
quelle élection présidentielle et mon
rôle au sénat n'est pas au delà de la
sagesse il est aussi de représenter nos
communes et nos collectivités
territoriales et là c'est une vision un
peu plus girondine que jacobine de la
chose parce qu'il est vrai que certaines
loin sont difficilement applicables à
l'échelle d'une commune il ya des maires
par exemple sur la la loi sru qui se
plaignent sru sur le logement social
logement social qui se plaignent des
lourdes pénalités ont également on a un
sujet sur l'intercommunalité notamment
dans les bouches du rhône avec cette
métropole xxl ou des compétences dites
de proximité ont été transférés en 2013
2014 à travers les lois notre île et
omap tam et on voit très bien qu'on ait
hobby d'un système est qu'il faut
repenser ce système donc c'est vrai que
c'est un éclairage différent que le
député qui est en place par rapport à un
projet politique
il ya une question qui vient d'être
posée dans le chat par nos gestes qui
vous écoutent et qui vous demande très
simplement
le sénat est il suffisant comme
contre-pouvoir face à une cinquième
république avec un ultra président je
vous ai dit qu'on était dans un régime
parlementaire
un grand sujet des consignes schiste on
n'est pas dans un régime présidentiel
et effectivement je rappelle quand même
que l'ambiguïté de la vème république
réside sur le fait que le gouvernement
est responsable devant le parlement et
dans le présent à peut avoir une motion
de censure on peut renverser le
parlement et l'assemblée nationale peut
renverser un gouvernement c'est arrivé
qu'une seule fois dans un cinquième
république
c'était 62 en 62 pour l'élection au
suffrage universel direct mais le
président lui n'est pas responsable mais
par contre c'est le président quel
pouvoir de dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale
donc là il ya quand même la halle
exécutif bicéphale fait que on sent très
bien que le président en fait c'est lui
le chef d'orchestre et c'est d'autant
plus vrai mais le sénat effectivement à
se re là et c'est je pense amplement
suffisant il faudrait peut-être faire
une réforme constitutionnelle
en ce qui concerne les lois qui ont pour
trait de la gestion des collectivités
territoriales on est on est les
représentants des collectivités
territoriales
toutes les lois relatives aux
collectivités territoriales arrive ce
qu'on appelle en première lecture au
sénat mais nous n'avons pas la dernière
lecture et je pense que si on voulait
véritablement jouer pleinement notre
rôle sur ces lois là effectivement le
sénat devrait être le gardien je
comprends la réponse que vous m'avez
fait que les institutionnels et je
reconnais le professeur de droit puis
que vous êtes mais j'ai quand même
reposer la question d'un point de vue
politique on a un président de la
république qui est à la tête d'un
conseil de défense qui prend des
décisions qu'il prend des décisions dans
le cas d'un état d'urgence et qui
gouvernent beaucoup par ordonnance vous
voyez où je veux en venir est ce que
vous vous sentez pas un peu seul le
sénat en ce moment dans un contexte de
quinquennat que vous avez décrit avec
une majorité la réplique en marche et
assemblée nationale qui est plutôt du
genre à voter
le doigt sur la couture du pantalon si
vous êtes en train de me dire qu'on a
mis le curseur de l'autre côté je pense
que oui je pense que le poids de
l'exécutif on est allé trop loin est
allé on est allé trop loin mais on est
allé trop loin pourquoi parce que les
effets de la 4è et 3è république c'est
ce fameux régime d'assemblée où c'était
le législatif tout puissant pour
renverser l'exécutif tous les tous les 6
mois voire même des fois toutes les
semaines
c'était ça la quatrième république et
dont on a mis le curseur de gaulle
voulait absolument éviter ça alors est
ce qu'il faut penser une réforme de nos
institutions pour rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs oui j'ai un deuxième sujet au
delà de l'exécutif c'est l'autorité
judiciaire le fameux pouvoir judiciaire
c'est à dire c'est à dire que ce n'est
pas au pouvoir judiciaire le pouvoir
judiciaire c'est la bouche de la loi
ouais et pour l'heure on a une inversion
de ses valeurs où on a parfois le lit
slater a parfois les yeux rivés sur les
arrêts du conseil d'état
les arrêts de la cour européenne les
arrêts où les décisions plutôt du
conseil constitutionnel et se trouvent
enfermés là dedans est ce que je veux
dire elle est non ça c'est aussi
important de travailler sur sur la le
fait de que législateur doit avoir le
les mains libres
alors effectivement alors je vais pas
faire un cours de droit mais on était
sûrs du légiste entrisme on arrive sur
une console du constitutionnalisme
seriez et c'est vrai que c'est un c'est
un excès il faudra je pense à l'avenir
corriger aussi vous avez parlé du
conseil constitionnel j'ai une question
de me carle qui vous demande ce que vous
pensez du monde de la nomination des
membres du conseil constitutionnel et ce
qui est un changement que vous
proposeriez c'est véritablement un sujet
pas tant sur les anciens présidents de
de la république s'est pas véritablement
le sujet on est admis pardon ah bon
emmanuel seront proposés ça s'est
relativement aux en sus d'arrêter de
mettre à la rigueur un sujet je ne dois
pas me battre là dessus je pense que
c'est pas véritablement sujet parce que
quand vous regardez bien il ne siège pas
oui donc on attend ça depuis le temps
que le conseil constitutionnel a retoqué
ses comptes comme non mais disons le
clairement de campagne bon ben aboud le
conseil constitutionnel françois
hollande a toujours dit moi j'y mettrai
pas les pieds j'y mettrai pas les pieds
je pense pas qu emmanuel macron que ça
soit en 2022 ou 2026 est soit d'un
allant pour leur adoption des sciences
russe au palais royal ça m'étonnerait
mais c'est surtout sur la nomination se
prennent un tiers un tiers un tiers un
tiers le président la république
alors on est à michelin est ce que c'est
une cour constitutionnelle de gaulle ne
voulait pas on rappelle que bien sûr la
création de la vème république
de gaulle avait vu le conseil
constitutionnel uniquement comme l'
arbitre entre le réglementaires et
législatives un essai tandis que 34 37
de la constitution en iran des 0 à 4
décision par an aujourd'hui avec la
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité introduite en 2008 71
500 décisions
c'est devenu une cour extrêmement
importante est-ce que fondamentalement
la nomination par le président de la
république le sait le président du sénat
le président l'assemblée nationale doit
pas être vu je pense que lui mais qu'est
ce qui va donner la légitimité de ces
juges constitutionnels
si ce n'est le suffrage universel
très bonne question on continue j'ai
beaucoup de questions pour vous les
internautes en plein de questions sur
tous ces sujets là la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale a décidé de
laisser tomber l'idée de la
proportionnelle en considérant que je
vous vois sourire considérant que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies
je suppose que le gaulliste que vous
êtes n'est pas très très fan de la
proportionnelle de quel proportionnelle
on parle une dose de proportionnelle
pour les élections législatives de
manière à mieux représenter des camps
politiques qui ne sont pas suffisamment
à cause du faible à cause du scrutin
majoritaire non mais le rassemblement
national le modem et les autres hui d
c'est un faux débat la proportion oui
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que regarder le
parlementarisme le la grande bretagne
c'est la mère du parlementarisme
ah oui quel est le scrutin en
grande-bretagne majorité scrutin
majoritaire à un tour
pourquoi pas mais d'un scrutin
l'idée de dire oui mais il faut une dose
proportionnelle pour que tous les partis
soient vous représentez si on veut être
juste c'est la proportionnelle intégrale
jeu pour qu'elle ose savez parfois une
dose si marine le pen estime puisqu'elle
fait 30% l'élection présidentielle qu'il
lui faut 30% de députés puisque c'est un
peu le message ou monsieur bayrou dit la
même chose qu'au départ il était sur une
proportionnelle intégrale puis l'a revu
ses prétentions un chemin entre les
mains de négocier mais la dose de
proportionnelle on peut dire s'est
jamais assez mais il a dose de
proportionnelle
à quoi ça sert d'avoir deux députés
rassemblement national ou 10 de toute
façon ils n'auront pas voix au chapitre
donc soit c'est de la proportionnelle
intégrale et là on retombe dans les
travers de la quatrième république
soit on est sur un scrutin majoritaire à
un ou deux tours et j'ajoute quand même
qu'à des accords qui sont faits entre
entre partis et l'idée c'est d'exprimer
la volonté générale
si c'est pour avoir une photographie à
l'instant t d'une opinion publique
c'est ça une élection c'est pour ça à
l'élection l'élection n'est pas ça
l'élection du président de la république
juste pour vous convaincre
on sait pas la photographie de l'opinion
publique puisque on est sur un scrutin
majoritaire et qu'à un moment donné il
faut bien s'entendre entre premier et
second tours puisqu'il n'y a que deux
candidats au second tour qualifiés là
aussi
moi j'irai plus loin est ce qu'il
faudrait pas avoir uniquement deux
candidats au second tour de l'élection
législative pour éviter des
triangulaires et une quadrangulaire à
vous iriez même jusqu à renforcer le
soudard majoritaire mais c'est
intéressant ce jeu lensois xvi ce qu'il
faut faire mais oh
repensons la chose et je pense pas que
cela semblait la volonté générale la
notion d'intérêt général n'est pas la
somme des intérêts particuliers
c'est vrai y at il des choses que vous
changeriez dans la vème république pour
l'adapter à la crise de la
représentation la crise de la démocratie
la défiance envers le personnel
politique exprimée notamment par exemple
alléger les jaunes oui oui
non moi ce qui me dérange le plus c'est
de comment on arrive à faire participer
les citoyens à certaines décisions
alors c'est du vol utilisés fortement le
référendum c'est vrai là on n'utilise
plus le président est tétanisé quand les
camps les gilets jaunes par l'aide d'un
référendum 17 citoyenne votre oreille a
fait tilt en vous disant sûr c'est
intéressant il ya une usure des oranges
des référendaires sur des sujets très
sensibles qui engage
[Musique]
la france dans une voie qui peut être
contestée par par là l'opinion l'opinion
publique
ou alors une mesure qui n'a pas été
discuté dans un projet présidentiel
pourquoi pas entrevoir le référendum et
ça c'est important parce que là c'est
vous parlez de photographie à l'instant
t de l'opinion alors certains ne me dise
a ajouté ben oui mais personne ne
répondent plus mais parce que c'est un
militaire un plébiscite ou pas mais
c'est parce qu'on utilise beaucoup trop
tard et qu'en fait ce qu'on devrait
changer ce n'est pas c'est la durée des
ja du mandat présidentiel
moi j'étais favorable au quinquennat et
avec le recul ainsi qu'avec le temps et
le fait qu on ait le même cadencement
avec les élections législatives sacré
les écueils qu'on est con évoqué tout à
l'heure je pense qu un septennat unique
serait la bonne formule nous
renouvelables non renouvelable cinq ans
c'est beaucoup trop court pour mettre en
oeuvre un projet politique et que à
l'intérieur de ces sept ans
effectivement l'instrument du référendum
pourrait être une solution sur des
sujets très sensibles très structurant
niveaux de la société
c'est une réflexion que je pose la
suppression du conseil économique social
et environnement et environnemental et
son remplacement par une convention
citoyenne tirés au sort est ce que c'est
une idée
c'est une question qui vous est posée
par d'époque man alors le tirage au sort
ça s'est il faudrait quand même dose et
le tirage au sort pour qu'on ait un
échantillon représentatif de la société
c'était le cas avec la convention
citoyenne non papa enfin c'est pas 150
personnes qui peuvent être représentatif
de l'ensemble de la société dans sa
diversité socioprofessionnelle sa parité
par les rats territoriale s'est
véritablement parce que le tirage au
sort s'est pas 67 millions dans une urne
et on en tire 150 noms c'est que voilà
donc après ça pose la question de
comment on tire au sort mais sur le fait
d'avoir alors je me méfie parce que
on est quand même dans un système de
démocratie représentative
c'est la base de notre démocratie
mais qu'on puisse avoir à un moment
donné un organe de consultation sur des
sujets essentiels au delà du céser qui
n'a pas grande utilité il faut l'avouer
alors que c'est dans la constitution
d'où la question d'où la question
pourquoi pas mais il faudrait regarder
en profondeur comment on monte
cet organe de consultation parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir des dessinateurs des sénatrices
depuis deux ans sur ce plateau
j'ai eu à peu près toutes les réponses
sur la convention citoyenne pour le
climat j'ai eu des dd voilà certains de
vos collègues qui trouve ça très
intéressant en disant que c'est à
réfléchir peut être qu'à l'avenir on
pourrait s'adjoindre effectivement
lettres de citoyens tirés au sort
d'autres de vos collègues qui ne
supporte pas l'idée qu'ils sont qui sont
vraiment l'hystérique à l'idée qu'on
puisse tirer au sort des citoyens et se
sentent menacés dans leur écharpe
tricolore
j'ai tout vu et ça m'intéresse
particulièrement votre réponse sur ce
sujet aux modalités de tirage au sort
mais pourquoi pas mettre ça à mettre ça
en oeuvre après effectivement ça pose le
problème de sa doit être uniquement un
organe consultatif mais ce n'est pas là
la convention citoyenne comme de décider
en lieu et place de ceux qui ont mandat
et c'était pas le sujet c'est la
proposition doit d'ailleurs arrivera sur
votre bureau des classes relais national
de raboter ça viendra dans l'est dans
les prochaines semaines une question de
bligg ou qui vous demande sur le
référendum sur l'article 1 de la
constitution proposée par président de
la république
allez-vous vous abstenir comme les
républicains de l'assemblée nationale
alors dans déjà sur une un projet de
loin constitution vous savez que le
sénat le même poids que l'assemblée
nationale seulement donc il suffit qu'on
change une virgule pour que vous avez le
pouvoir d'empêcher que vers le faire à
manger de loin repartent sais pas c'est
pas l'idée mais tous les conseils du
constitue chérissent 10 la chose
suivante nous avons une charte de
l'environnement adossée à la
constitution depuis 2005 qui a valeur
constitutionnelle et qui
filles largement à défendre le climat ou
en tout cas les objectifs
constitutionnels pour préserver
l'environnement
ça s'est vu dans trois décisions du
conseil constitutionnel qui a été qu'ils
ont été rendues depuis depuis un an un
an et demi où tout converge vers le fait
que le climat l'environnement est
également un droit constitutionnel au
même titre que la liberté d'entreprendre
la liberté d'association etc etc
et le fait de d'essayer de mettre dans
l'article 1er cette notion de garantir
la préservation de l'environnement
n'apportera rien insisté de la confusion
par rapport au juge constitutionnel
d'accord donc c'est encore pire qu'à ce
que vous prenez l'article qui est prévu
par rapport à l'article 6 de la charte
de l'environnement
et là vous voyez une différence c'est
que quand on dit garantir c'est qu'on
doit avoir une obligation de résultat
quand vous dites favoriser ou prendre
part à la préservation de
l'environnement
c'est une obligation de moyens et donc
vous voyez des interprétations que
pourrait avoir le le juge
constitutionnel dans la matière une
question de news qui vous demander ce
que vous êtes favorable à l'insertion
d'un paragraphe sur les racines
chrétiennes de la france dans la
constitution comme beaucoup des membres
de votre parti
ou est-ce que l'on de tomber dans une
zone jugée favorable au projet à la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle de
philippe bas qui voulait à l'article 1er
de la constitution insisté sur le fait
que nulle personne par ses croyances par
sa religion ne peut s'exonérer de la
règle commune
d'accord mais je ne peux pas dire je
suis favorable au fait de dire que la
france a des racines chrétiennes puisque
là j'en reviens de discussion du départ
sur le communautarisme à ions commence à
cibler les racines chrétiennes de la
france c'est qu'on exclut une partie de
notre population
c'est bien pour ça que vous est posée
cette question là c'est que du coup on
voit qu'effectivement tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord
là dessus une question à nouveau de
depok mam qui voulez vous demander ce
qu'il existe en france des garde-fous
contre un scénario à la trump en france
où un président refuserait les résultats
d'une élection
déjà le président sait c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur qui organise
les élections
le conseil constitutionnel qui valide
c'est le garde-fou c'est le conseil
constitutionnel donc je dirais que dans
notre constitution dans nos institutions
le scénario à la trump ne peut pas ne
peut pas exister ou sinon c'est un coup
d'état un coup d'état avec l'armée mais
peu de choses voilà c'était autre chose
une question sur la loi sécurité globale
qui va qui est actuellement en
discussion au sénat
bla bla 59 vous demande si la charte de
laïcité qui est imposée aux associations
dans le cadre de la loi sécurité globale
et un danger constitutionnel pas du tout
y a pas de risque que le conseil
national censure pas du tout pourquoi il
censure est ce parce que c'est une
limitation de la liberté associative
pardon un conditionnement de la liberté
associative à la signature d'une charte
parce que la charte de la laïcité c'est
quand même la laïcité a quand même un
objectif constitutionnel donc après
celle équilibre entre les deux on ne
refuse pas enfin le texte de soi la
sécurité globale n'est pas un frein à la
liberté d'association
on s'était pas en tout cas c'est pas
l'objectif qui est prôné d'accord mais
c'est pas un risque non plus non ok
selon ok à ce sujet d'ailleurs la loi
sécurité globale et une proposition de
loi qui donc n'est pas passée par le
conseil d'état philippe bas avait eu
cette phrase magnifique en dix ans elle
a été écrite avec les pieds cette loi il
faudra la récré avec les mains oui c'est
ce qui a été fait au sénat ben justement
mais justement il a mis en pratique ce
qu'il a ce qu ils apprenaient sais ce
que c'est normal que les propositions de
loi ne passe pas sous le sous les yeux
du conseil d'état c'est le circuit
normal mais il faut inventer c'est une
oie enfin c'est en fait ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire c'est que le gouvernement
rockalies fille en projet de loi et
passe par le conseil d'état mais vous
savez c'était au projet de loi comment
c'est un faux projet de la sueur bien
sûr avons le mais vous savez ils sont
pas la première moi j'ai été la
rapporteur du projet de loi organique
sur l'élection du président de la
république il ya eu un amendement
du gouvernement au sénat déposé au sénat
donc ce n'était pas dans le texte
initial pour faire le vote par
anticipation à travers des machines à
voter mais c'est une technique classique
est là aussi
comment c'est une technique classique
déposé un amendement pour passer devant
le conseil d'état sur des trucs l'élite
mais pas de conseil d'état l'assemblée
nationale n'a pas statué non plus encore
et donc nous demander nous sénateurs de
de se positionner sur quelque chose qui
n'est pas dans l'adn de la vème
république
parce que le vote par anticipation vous
savez quel ce fameux débat entre deux
tours qui est un moment fort d'une
campagne présidentielle imaginez un seul
instant que ça puisse modifier votre
jugement en disant bas tout content
s'est vu les arguments qui a exposé tel
ou tel candidat
eh bien je préfère telle candidate dans
le cadre du débat trop tard j'ai voté le
dimanche précédent donc là aussi il ya
une rupture d'égalité devant devant le
suffrage en 2011 vous avez soutenu une
thèse on l'a dit tout à l'heure une
thèse alors l'époque vous avez fait une
thèse sur la démocratie
oui sur l'innovation de la démocratie
par internet oui vous avez été vachement
en avance sur toutes les évolutions
qu'on a vu depuis lâchement j'avais
prédit la montée du populisme carrément
dans la thèse vous pouvez la consulter
en disant attention si les outils
technologiques les nouveaux médias ne
sont mal utilisés ces des outils
fantastiques
à l'heure actuelle on à la géniale moi
je mais attention parce qu'il ya une
forme de radicalité des propos qui sont
tenus et les rires là peut-être des fois
on raccourcit notre pensée et ça donne
lieu donc à à la montée des extrêmes
c'était un peu le le sens et que j'étais
pour une démocratie participative à
travers ces mais ces nouveaux médias
une démocratie participative à travers
des modérateurs alors j'ai des questions
là-dessus
d'internautes qui voulez vous demander
par exemple est-ce que vous pensez que
le csa devrait contrôlée en partie par
exemple c'est une idée le csa met qu'une
autorité devrait contrôler le respect du
temps de parole est méritée ce genre de
choses sur les réseaux sociaux
ça serait très dur à contrôler c'est
malheureusement très dur non je pense
que au delà du contrôle
c'est surtout le fait de des
administrateurs des réseaux sociaux des
groupes discussions doivent quand même
avoir ce rôle de modérateur pour éviter
les débordements ou des prises de
positions totalement radical voire
parfois qui vont en vers l'injure parce
qu'on n'est pas sûr du débat à ce
moment-là rationnelle et le fait que ce
soit des entreprises privées qui du coup
est ce rôle démocratique ça pose une
difficulté son loyer fondamentalement ça
pose la question de comment on gère
vous avez les réseaux sociaux c'est moi
j'appelle ça des multitudes de
conversations privées dans l'espace
public
et c'est pour ça qu'on se rend pas
compte mais en fait on est dans l'espace
public et certains je pense ne tiendrait
pas ses propos au café du commerce du
court 1 devant une multitude de
personnes vous voyez à propos de à
propos de d'outils numériques utilisés
pour la démocratie participative le
sénat a lancé une plate forme de
pétition en ligne et une première
pétition a obtenu les cent mille
signatures c'est la pétition sur
l'allocation adulte handicapé le sénat a
d'ailleurs adopté
c'est une bonne voie savidan section
serait bon de vous envoyer ça c'est un
moyen d'utiliser les nouveaux médias
pour que les citoyens à travers une
pétition puisse participer puisse forcer
la décision en disant oui ça il faut le
faire ça nous intéresse
ça concerne des sujets de société
actuelle une dernière question un peu
mais tu as mais quand vous voyez
françois hollande qui va sur twitch
emmanuel macron qui fait une vidéo avec
des youtuber vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose c'est de la communication à
bas coûts non non je pense que fin il
faut vivre avec son temps je pas là
dessus je serai moins pas sur toulouse à
sion tweet leur choix c'est comme si que
fait le président de la république sur
twitch et le sénateur et surtout non non
je pense qu'il faut vivre aussi avec ces
nouveaux médias avec ses formats qui
sont différents parce que là vous savez
il ya très peu d'émissions de télé qui
vous permettent de faire cette
discussion qu'on a eue
sans être interrompus quasi sans être
coupés et ça je tiens à vous féliciter
parce que le format long mais je sais
pas il ya pas jean paul agon riz le
format permet au moins de débattre et
d'aller jusqu'au bout de ses idées
merci stéphane rudulier mars avoir
accepté l'invitation merci vous êtes
prêté l'exercice merci à vous d'avoir
regardé cette émission avec des
dictionnaires bon bonne fin de semaine à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
oh